oh hi welcome to game life on this
weekly wrapup wired editors will tell
you what's new and exciting in the world
of video games this week we've got a
look at one of the biggest new games for
the Nintendo 3ds resident evil
revelations we've also got a review of a
new iphone and ipad puzzle game that's
an addictive combination of Tetris and
Scrabble but first let's look at this
week's big news Bethesda said that this
week it will release the Skyrim creation
kit allowing you to create your own
adventures in the massively popular
role-playing game if you're finally
finished with the hundreds of hours of
quests and side quests in the latest
Elder Scrolls game get ready for an
avalanche of new content all created
with tools just like the ones used by
the game's designers budding game makers
can download the creation kit for free
through the steam service if you just
want to play you'll be able to find all
the best user-generated adventures on
the Skyrim workshop on Steam Methos de
says the Skyrim creation kit will be
released this week now wired magazine's
senior editor Peter Ruben has been glued
to his iPad the last few weeks playing
an addictive new game and he's here to
tell us all about puzzle juice so as
anyone who knows me and my gaming habits
knows the only thing I love more than
portal his word games you give me
anything that has the slightest whiff of
boggle and I'm going to hole up
somewhere and ignore everyone that means
anything to me I'm happy to say it's
been a long time since the game is
pissed off my friends and family as much
as puzzle juice the game which was
designed by to devs one of whom worked
on the misadventures of PB winterbottom
is essentially an ungodly mashup of
Tetris boggle and bejeweled the first
layer is a Tetris clone multi colored
shapes descend into the play space you
rotate and fit them together as best you
can then there's a bejeweled layer every
intact line you create or every time you
tap an area of three or more contiguous
boxes the boxes in lines turn into
letters which you can then find words in
and trace boggle style with your finger
causing them to vanish or even better
explode
meanwhile the game's presenting you with
the series of increasingly harder
objectives in order to level up puzzle
juice is chaotic it's a times
overwhelming but despite not having game
center achievements it's one of my
favorite iOS titles of the past year in
fact Qui Qui get a reading rainbow sound
effect in here we'd all like to thank
Peter for putting down his iPad long
enough to tell us about that game now
unlike some people I actually still
prefer playing portable games that use
you know a joystick buttons that kind of
standard stuff and one of the biggest
ones this week is resident evil
revelations for the Nintendo 3ds this
latest entry in the classic series of
touching zombie meets shotgun love
stories pushes your 3ds hardware to the
limit so crank up your 3d slider all the
way to maximum and let the graphics
assault your eyeballs if you remember
resident evil as being a slow-paced slog
through a creepy mansion while armed
with only a few bullets rest assured
those days are over revelations is a
run-and-gun game full of non-stop action
and also full of genuinely creepy
moments the game jumps between several
different playable characters in a
series of episodic chapters which
basically tell the origin story of the
classic characters Chris Redfield and
Jill Valentine they travel through a
cruise ship on which wait for it
something has gone terribly wrong or
totally right if you're one of the evil
people who are trying to let loose a
swarm of creatures on the world besides
your trusty array of firearms you've
also got a scanner which you can use to
sweep each room for hidden items but you
can also use the scanner to gather data
on all of the different enemies which
rewards you with extra green herbs that
refill your health you get more data if
the enemies are still alive and really
close to you when you scan them so
there's a fun risk/reward balance there
resident evil revelations is full of
storyline sequences and very few of them
make any sense whatsoever yes I realize
it might be asking a bit too much of a
Resident Evil game to make sense but
maybe I'm still holding out hope that
Capcom will one day create a game with a
story that's not completely insane
bioorganic weapons are a global to start
working with arrested world of the
raccoon city of Aksum City incident city
and assuming my desire to reveal I'm
going to tell them everything I've
always valued your friendship Leon stay
where you are
mr. president
it's not my fault I did this
what are you talking about ninety
percent of the population in tall oaks
has been infected with the virus that
runs out to about 70,000 hostels Raccoon
City all over again
Oh
you want to tell me what's in there it's
better if I show you I can't keep
running away
I have to face the truth accept
responsibility
hd2 lvg now a change to your mission
suppressed a bioterror a break while
proceeding to point a subspace output HQ
this is working thought we need backup
it's regenerating all right first things
first
the front another two other
witnesses over would be our double use
those are extra
as a mercenary
I'm gonna let anything happen to you
no no not me just my blood well the
world can have it someone ponies up the
dough to what she's done to us how many
of our men are dead because of that fan
right there with you captain but your
personal been dead isn't gonna get us
anywhere
resident evil 6 what are you gonna do
I